The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
we'll start quickly
going over the concept questions
for the homework this week.
So you have a two rotor system.
It says, if you
give it a deflection
at a exactly the mode
shape of mode two,
what frequency
components do expect
the transient response to have?
So most people said only omega
2, but quite a few people
said both.
So this introduction
to vibration
that we have been
doing for the last few
lectures-- my goal in it is
to have you folks go away
with a pretty good conceptual
understanding of the basics
of vibration, and
on the final exam,
I'm not going to have
you derive anything,
like finding the natural
frequencies of a 3
by 3 degree of freedom system,
solving a sixth order system
in omega squared.
I won't do that kind of thing
to you, but questions like this
are really fair game.
So if we did this business
bimodal analysis--
and we did an example the
other day where with the system
we had here, if you deflect
it in exactly the shape of one
mode, what kind of
response do you get?
Initial conditions
that are shaped exactly
like one the mode shapes.
AUDIENCE: It has exactly
that natural frequency in it.
PROFESSOR: Well, it'll not only
have that natural frequency
in it, but if you deflect
it initially in the mode
shape, what will the
responding motion look like?
AUDIENCE: Just the mode shape.
PROFESSOR: Just
like the mode shape,
and if the motion is in
a particular mode shape,
it will be at-- this
is transient vibration.
No external force.
You deflect it and let it go.
You will see only
motion in that mode
if you give it an initial
deflection exactly in that mode
shape.
If you went to the other mode,
and deflected it that way,
and let go, it would
change frequency,
and it would vibrate
only in that shape.
And any other
combination of motions
is some linear sum of
those two mode shapes.
Any other allowable
motion of the system
can be made up of some weighted
sum of the two mode shapes,
right?
And that's the
amount of each mode
that you get-- is
the weighted sum.
What are the weightings?
If the weightings
are 1, 0, then it's
all one mode and not of another.
If it takes some of
each mode to give you
the initial deflected shape,
that's how much of each mode
you get.
So the answer to this
question is only mode two.
OK, next.
I forget what you were given.
Apply the concept.
Which mode is likely to dominate
the steady state response
for the excitation of part D?
So it was probably being
excited harmonically
at the natural
frequency of mode two.
So which mode?
So harmonic
excitation, which mode
do you expect to respond the
most when you excite it at one
of the natural frequencies?
AUDIENCE: I'd say [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: At that
natural frequency.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because that's
what the eigenvalue is.
PROFESSOR: Well, there's
an eigenvalue there,
but now we're talking about
steady state response.
What's the transfer
function of a single degree
of freedom system look like?
Just trace it in the air.
This is a response per unit
input, and where does it go?
Way up high--
AUDIENCE: At the resonance.
PROFESSOR: At the resonance.
And so if you have two 2
degree of freedom system,
how many resonances do you have?
What do you think
the transfer function
is going to look like for a
two degree of freedom system
if you just plotted it just
plot as a function of frequency?
AUDIENCE: Double peak.
PROFESSOR: Double peak.
So the transfer
function is likely to do
that at one frequency and that
at the next natural frequency.
And that's what we're going
to talk about today, in fact.
OK so if you excited the
second natural frequency
and it's lightly damped,
it's likely to be dominated
by that modal response.
In that question, is it
guaranteed to be only that mode
responding, even if you derive
it at the natural frequency?
Another way to
saying this question,
can the first mode
have some response
at any frequency you
excite the system at?
Sure.
It has transfer function.
It's continuous in frequency.
It just won't be very big.
OK, next.
For what value is
omega over omega
n is the force transmitted
to the wall going
to be the greatest.
So this is-- when
we make this, this
is now we're doing--
it's rotating around.
OK, so this thing
is rotating mass now
at a constant frequency.
So it's got a static imbalance.
And at what frequency would you
expect the force transmitted
to the wall be the greatest?
AUDIENCE: At resonance.
PROFESSOR: At resonance, because
that's when you get the most--
AUDIENCE: The most response.
PROFESSOR: Greatest response.
And the force transmitted to
the wall is through the spring
and through the dash
pot, and the bigger
the motions, the bigger
those forces are going to be.
OK, next.
And so this is-- now, if
you'll account for the spring,
do you expect the counting
for the mass of the spring
to increase the predicted
natural frequency
or decrease it?
AUDIENCE: Decrease.
PROFESSOR: Decrease.
Natural frequencies
behave like square root
of k/m kind of thing.
And if you do anything
that drives up the m,
frequency is going to go down.
Another way of asking
the same question
is, if you neglect
mass when you're
estimating the natural
frequency of a system,
which way are you
likely to be in error?
This system, normally we just
ignore the mass of the springs,
and we calculate the
natural frequency
as square root of
k/m, and we're almost
certain to be-- predict what?
Too high or too low?
AUDIENCE: Too high.
PROFESSOR: Too high,
because we've ignored
some mass in the system.
OK, next.
I think that's it.
I want to get on
with today's lecture.
We have done
vibration from point
of view of single
degree of freedom
systems, transient response,
and steady escape response.
And then we've started looking
at multiple degree of freedom
systems, but we
actually started it
from the point of view
of modal analysis,
and we looked at two
degree of freedom systems,
and found the
modal contributions
of each of the modes, and sort
of did them one at a time.
So is there another
way-- one of you
asked me after class
last time, well,
can't you just solve the
differential equations directly
and not bother with separating
the modes out and figuring out
the modal contributions.
The answer is yes, and you
do it via transfer functions,
except now you will
need more than one
if you have more than
one degree of freedom.
So that's what we'll
focus on today.
And we're going to do it by
thinking about the example
actually from the homework.
So in the homework
you have this problem
of this cart with this
pendulum hanging off of it.
And we-- in problem
three, I think it is--
is say, OK, now the
pendulum is going
to go around a
constant rate, and it's
going to turn this into a
rotating imbalance problem.
And I shorten it up so it's just
a little mass spinning around.
You have k1, c1, x1 here.
And I think you have
draw in there as theta.
This is point A
about which it spins.
And you know the
non-linear equation
to motion for treating this as
a two degree of freedom system,
just pendulum on a cart.
And then nonlinear
equation of motion.
And I'm going to
put subscripts here,
and I'm going to call
this coordinate x1,
because we're going to
need a second coordinate--
or actually, do we?
What am I saying?
We don't need to do that.
Just x will do.
We do need the m1
and m2, though.
And so that is all-- I'm
going to move the remaining
stuff to the right hand side.
So this is your
nonlinear m2L theta
double dot cos theta
minus theta dot
squared sine theta on
the right hand side.
And I think I need a
minus if I do that.
Now, what I do in
this problem, I
say let's let theta dot equals
omega, and that's a constant.
And so that says
theta double dot is 0.
When you do that, then
this term goes away,
and this becomes omega
squared minus times a minus.
This equals 1/2 m2L
omega squared sine.
And theta is just omega t.
So by forcing what was
previously an unknown variable
that you had the
solve in this-- you
had two equations
and two unknowns
because you had two
generalized coordinates
it took to describe the motion
of this thing, x and theta.
Now, once you prescribe
theta and it's given,
it's no longer a variable.
It's no longer a coordinate
in your generalized--
in your equations of motion
that you have to solve for,
and it reduces this equation to
the equation of a single degree
of freedom system.
On the left hand side is
the response quantities
just like usual-- mx double
dot plus bx dot plus kx.
And on the right hand side
is our harmonic excitation,
and that's this unbalanced
mass going around and around.
So this has the form here.
This is some-- if you want
to think of it this way,
this is some F0, and it
looks like sine omega t.
So this is just a single degree
of freedom system excited
by harmonic excitation,
and you know
it has a transfer
function, and you
know that there's
going to be a resonance
at the natural
frequency of the system.
And if you don't like
working with sine omega t,
you could say, well, let's
measure omega theta from here
if you want to, and now
that's cosine omega t.
OK, so that's sort
of the set up.
Let me say one-- if
I asked you to solve
for the magnitude of
the response x1 here,
how would you do it?
So this is now a single degree
of freedom system excited
by harmonic excitation.
Steady state response--
how do you do it?
This you do have to know.
AUDIENCE: Transfer function.
PROFESSOR: Use a
transfer function.
So this going to be the
magnitude of the force
times the magnitude of the HxF
of omega transfer function,
and that's how you get the
magnitude of the response,
and it happens to
be a resonance.
Then you'd be at the peak,
and if you're not a resonance,
wherever you happen
to be in frequency
is where you would
evaluate this,
and there's your response.
Now, a few years ago--
every year-- twice a year,
in fact-- and they're
coming up in January,
we have doctoral
exams for students
who want to do PhDs in
mechanical engineering,
and most departments
at MIT have these also.
And in the dynamics portion,
there's an oral exam part.
There's a written exam,
also, but in the oral exam
in this particular year,
gave a single degree
of freedom system.
And we posed-- and
we all know that,
if we excite this thing
with a harmonic excitation,
some F1 cosine-- and I
will use complex notation,
because we're going to need
it in a minute-- some F1 e
to the i omega t.
That's the excitation.
We know what the steady state
response of this looks like.
The magnitude looks like
that transfer function.
But we posed-- so most
would be doctoral students
would know all about single
degree of freedom [INAUDIBLE].
So we posed the
following question.
Well, we know that
the response of this
is going to do
something like that,
and you evaluate this
at whatever frequency
you're interested in,
including right at resonance.
And the question
we asked is, is it
possible to add a second spring
and a second mass, m2 and k2,
such that-- so is it possible
to pick a k2 and an m2,
such that, with this
excitation on here,
the motion of that
thing will be 0?
And in order to
solve this problem,
as soon as you put this on here
and assume it's sliding along--
it can't fall.
It only has horizontal
possible motion,
and we'd give it some coordinate
describing its motion x2.
So now how many degrees of
freedom does this problem have?
Two.
How many equations of
motion do you expect?
How many peaks in
a transfer function
would you expect to see?
Two resonances.
So now we need to
know how to find
transfer functions for a
multiple degree of freedom
system.
enough in everything I've said
about two degree of freedom
systems, everything
is generalizable to n
degrees of freedom.
Though, what I'm
going to show you
now is how to do transfer
functions for multi-degree
of freedom systems,
and I'm going
to do it by way of example of
a two a degree of freedom one,
but just keep in mind that you
can completely generalize this.
So there is my system-- two
masses, two springs-- and I
could even have dash
spots in here-- a c1,
and I might have a c2.
And I could even, in
general, additionally have
a force acting on this
second mass, which
I'll call F2e to the I omega t.
So that's the completely
general problem now.
Now, the equations of
motion for this system
you could write down.
We've done it many times
now-- this particular system
even-- but we could
write them in matrix form
as mx double dot
plus cx dot plus k.
Stiffness matrix x
equals and excite
the excitation in this
two degree-- well,
I'll just keep this
is completely general.
This is any n degree of freedom
system, some Fe to the i omega
t.
So here's kind of
an important point.
We solve for the motion of
a multiple degree of freedom
system to a harmonic input.
We do it one
frequency at a time.
So this doesn't
mean that I could
have force on the
first mass at omega 1
or at some omega, and
force of the second mass
at some other omega.
I'd never do that
at the same time.
It's a linear system.
Superposition holds.
You do things one frequency
at a time, get the answer,
and if you have
another frequency part,
you do that separately,
then add the two answers.
So this is assumed.
All the forces
acting on the masses
are assumed to occur
at one frequency,
but you can't have
different amplitudes
on the different masses.
So that's what that means.
So this then for the two
degree of freedom system-- F,
for examplet-- F of t
would be some constant F1.
Another constant magnitude,
F2e to the i omega t.
That's what we mean by that.
Actually, if you do that,
if these are just constants,
some constant force vector
applied at a single frequency,
what frequency do
you expect to see
in the response of the system?
Steady state response.
AUDIENCE: Driving frequency.
Driving frequency.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's a
linear system more or less
since you really
want to go away with.
This is an intralinear system.
Steady state response
of a linear system--
the frequency in is
the frequency out.
Always true.
So we expect to see a solution.
We're going to get a
solution of the form x
equals some magnitude
vector times an e
to the i omega t also.
And the magnitude
might be complex,
because it there be phase
angles there due to damping
and so forth, but nonetheless,
they're constants.
This part is a constant
vector, and that's
its frequency dependence.
And if we know that is
true, then we can say,
well, take the time
derivative of that.
The only time dependent
part is the e to i omega t.
So x dot becomes i omega
xe to the i omega t.
And x double dot becomes
minus omega squared xe
to the i omega t.
So we can substitute this, this,
and this into this equation.
Of course, these are
matrix equations.
And when you do
that, minus omega
squared times the mass
matrix i omega times the c
matrix plus k xe to the i omega
t equals Fe to the i omega t.
You can get rid of
these, and now you
have a algebraic equation that's
no longer a function of time--
function of your
original mass, damping,
and stiffness matrices.
And it's certainly a
function of frequency.
And if you think
back, this is how
we derive the transfer function
for a single degree of freedom
system.
And this statement is true for
single degree of freedom, too.
With single degree of
freedom, that's just the mass.
That's just the damping, and
that's just the stiffness.
And you could solve directly
for the hx/f transfer function,
but with multiple
degrees of freedom,
we can't just quite
divide this out.
This piece here is known
as the-- I'll write
it is z omega-- z of omega.
This is known as the
impedance matrix.
And if I want to solve,
I'm looking for x.
I want to know my solution x.
So this is essentially
of the form z.
It's a matrix times x, a
vector, equals F, a vector.
And just using what you
know about linear algebra,
to solve for x, you just
multiply through by z inverse.
So x equals z
inverse F. All right?
And z is a two degree
of freedom system. z is
a two by two matrix with
frequency and everything in it,
but it's a two by two.
So z inverse will
be a two by two.
And for two by two, we can
just write down the answer,
but let's see.
I'll write out z of omega here.
So just to be clear
about what all this is,
z of omega is this,
and in this problem,
that's minus omega squared
times a mass matrix, which
looks like m1, 0, 0, m2.
And you add to that a damping
matrix, i omega, times c.
The c is from the
equations of motion.
c1 plus c2, minus c2, minus
c2, c2, and plus our k matrix.
k1 plus k2, minus
k2, minus k2 k2.
So that's what the z of
omega actually looks like.
And so you would collect--
so it's a two by two matrix,
and its upper left term is
minus omega squared m1 plus i
omega times this plus that.
Collect them all together.
And this has a form--
this collects together
in a form we call
z11, z12, z21, z22.
And very often z12
and z21 are symmetric.
Not always.
The kind of problems
we generally do here,
they will be, and it will
be generally symmetric
if your coordinate
system is measured
from a static
equilibrium position.
So if you've been
doing 2001, there's
a thing called Maxwell's
reciprocal theorem,
which proves this for
the stiffness matrix.
They essentially
need to be measured
from static
equilibrium positions,
but for today's example,
this is indeed symmetric.
Minus c2, minus c2,
minus k2, minus k2.
0, 0.
Everything is symmetric.
So we'll take advantage of
that, and I'll write out
one of the components
here-- z11,
for example, when you
collect the terms together,
is in general, it would be
minus omega squared m11 plus i
omega c11 plus k11, the corner
elements of these three pieces.
And in this problem, that's
minus omega squared m1 plus i
omega c1 plus c2
plus k1 plus k2.
You just substitute in
this, this, and this.
So that's z11, for
example, and the other ones
you can figure out what each
of the other terms would be.
All right, so we've said that we
want to know what the x's are.
And we know that we can get
that by doing z inverse times F.
And this gives us
our definition.
This z inverse is our H, our
transfer function matrix,
times F. So just by
getting z inverse,
we get this little set of
four transfer functions
that we're interested in.
So H is an N by N matrix
of transfer functions.
So in a two by two-- or
for the two by two case,
our N equals 2.
We know we can write out
directly what z inverse is.
And z inverse-- z22, minus z12,
minus z12 when it's symmetric,
z11, all over-- how
should I write it?
All over the determinant of z.
So this is the determinant.
So the determinant
of z [INAUDIBLE]
do these double bars.
So this over the determinant
is the inverse of that matrix,
and this gives you
a new result, which
is H11, H12, H12, H22, where
Hij-- this is the response at i
per unit force at j.
And I've made this-- I took
advantage of the symmetry here,
but this one would
normally be called 21,
so this is response at 1
caused by the force at 1.
So we have forces
in our problem.
One is the force
on the main mass.
So how much response do you
get at the main first mass
due to the force
on the first mass?
This is how much
response you get
on the first mass due to the
excitation in the second mass.
Response on the second mass due
to the excitation on the first.
Response in the second
mass due to the excitation
on the second mass.
So you get four possible
contributions here.
And the determinant
of z for a two by two
is also very straightforward.
z11, z22, minus z12 squared.
So we can and will work out
exactly what the algebra tells
us for this two by two case.
So we've already been discussing
it, but what do you expect.
Let's say let's
look at this one.
What do you suppose
the response at 1
due to a harmonic
excitation at 1--
what do you think the sketch of
the magnitude of H11 of omega
would look like as a
function a frequency?
AUDIENCE: Will C12 and
C21 always be symmetric?
PROFESSOR: No, but for the kind
of problems we do, probably.
And if it's simple beams, or
masses connected by springs,
if you choose your generalized
coordinates in a way that
is, for example, measuring
the displacement of each mass
from an inertial static
equilibrium starting point,
it'll be symmetric.
But if you measure the-- even
in this two degree of freedom,
I can make it non-symmetric
just by choosing the coordinate
for the second mass as to be
relative to the first mass.
Soon as you do that, it
makes it non-symmetric.
You can still solve for transfer
function and everything,
but it gets messier.
Though, notice I picked
coordinates-- x1 relative
to the inertial frame, x2
relative to the same inertial
frame-- and they're both
measuring displacement
from a static
equilibrium position.
Then they are symmetric.
And there's the
determinant we need,
and this determinant-- see,
this is divided into all four
of these terms.
So these four transfer functions
all share the same denominator.
They all have the
same denominator.
So I just want you to
use your intuition.
Tell me what this is
going to look like.
What's it look like for a
single degree of freedom system?
It's HxF for a single
degree of freedom--
it's H11 for a single
degree of freedom system
as a response of those
systems to a harmonic
force on that single mass,
and that looks like what?
Peak, right?
This one-- what do you think
it's going to look like?
Show me again.
OK, but I see one peak.
How many peaks?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
two degrees of freedom.
PROFESSOR: Two different
natural frequencies.
This thing is going to
look something like this,
and I don't know quite
how it behaves in here,
but it's going to
do that for sure.
It's going to have two
resonances-- this one at omega
1, this one at omega 2.
We already know that because
we did it by modal analysis.
We know each mode is going
to have a resonance in it.
OK, so let's find out
exactly what it looks like.
So for this two degree
of freedom system,
there's an F1 and an F2,
and we're looking for x1.
So x1 x2 here equals H11,
H12, H12, H22 times F1 F2.
So if I want to solve for
x1, H11 F1 plus H12 F2.
And for the problem
I'm going to solve
today, I'm going to let F2
be 0, just to keep it simple,
but also to address
the original question
we ask the doctoral students.
You have a force
on the first mass.
Can I add a mass and
spring to it in such a way
that I can make the response
of the first mass go to 0.
So there is no second force.
There's only a first force,
and so this term goes away.
And so this problem,
x1, is H11 F1.
Therefore, we need to
know what H11 looks like.
So H11 is going to be z22
divided by the determinant.
So x1 is going to be z22 over
Z11, Z22 minus Z12 squared
times F1.
And actually I can
do this so-- and I'm
going to let, for
now, damping be 0,
because it also simplifies
it for the purposes
of illustration today.
And that's how I was posed
to the doctoral student.
Didn't even show any damping.
It was just a simple
system, a string and a mass.
How can you do this?
So we'll let the damping
be 0 and that considerably
simplifies things then.
So Z11 is minus omega
squared m1 plus k1 plus k2.
z22 minus omega
squared m2 plus k2.
And z12 just minus k2.
So now these are pretty
simple expressions,
and all I have to do
is plug them in here.
And notice what's going to
happen. z11 times z22-- that's
something involving
omega squared
times another term
involving omega squared.
It's going to give
you a polynomial
and omega to the fourth.
This is the polynomial
that has two roots,
and the two routes are?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
frequencies.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
natural frequencies.
The determinant of the z
matrix is the same problem
you solve when you've
found the roots
of the characteristic equation.
It is the
characteristic equation
for the system, the
denominator, the determinant
of the z matrix.
Therefore it's going to be a
fourth order equation in omega.
It'll give you two
routes for omega squared.
They're your two undamped
natural frequencies
when we leave damping
out of this expression,
and they'd be damped--
the damped expressions--
they'd have complex stuff
if you leave in the damping.
But they give us our two roots,
and they go in the denominator.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If we set the
denominator or the determinant
of the matrix equal
to 0 and solve,
you get the modal frequencies?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That denominator is the
characteristic equation
that we did when we set it up
to do the natural frequencies.
Same equation.
So we know that this thing
has two roots, one at each
of the natural frequencies.
And when omega is at a
natural frequency, what
is the value of this
characteristic equation?
Well, no.
The characteristic equation.
Think of the denominator.
Add a root, that
expression goes to?
0.
So you're dividing by 0.
That's what causes the peaks.
That's where the
peaks come from.
denominator goes to 0,
and that's at the
natural frequencies.
OK, so x1 for this
problem equals H11F1,
and now we can
just write it out.
H11 is minus omega squared
m2 plus k2 times F1.
And the denominator, the
characteristic equation,
is minus omega
squared m1 plus k1
plus k2 times
minus omega squared
m2 plus k2 minus k2 squared.
So this whole thing
down here-- there's
your characteristic equation.
You multiply it out.
You get your fourth
order polynomial.
Solve it.
You get two roots,
but this is now
a total expression for the
response we were looking for.
So right away this
gives me the answer
to the question that was posed
to the doctoral students.
So is there a value-- can
you set k2 and m2 such
that you can make the
response of the system 0
at a particular omega?
All you have to do is make
the numerator go to 0, right?
So if you make this
go to 0, x goes to 0.
So x1 equals 0 when minus omega
squared m2 plus k2 equals zero,
and that happens when k2
over m2 equals omega squared.
So how many-- once you set k2
and m2, how many frequencies
does this happen at?
At how many different
operating points
can you make the response
of that main mass go to 0?
Well, just one.
Once you choose k1 and m2,
whatever you've chosen to be,
they give you some
value of omega.
And when I said I was kind of
vague about what happens here,
this is H11.
Looks like that.
Right here is when omega
squared equals k2/m2.
AUDIENCE: So when it's
at the frequency that
makes the numerator 0, wouldn't
it also-- I don't remember.
Would the denominator be 0 also?
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
Because, look at
the picture here.
Where are the two natural
frequencies of this system?
There's one here,
and there's one here.
And that's when the
denominator goes to 0.
When the denominator
goes to 0, the response
goes to infinity
with no damping.
So the system has two
natural frequencies-- one
to either side of this point.
So I've picked kind of
a particular example
to illustrate the use
of a transfer function,
and the fact that
you can have transfer
functions for multiple
degree of freedom systems,
and they essentially become
transfer function matrices.
And you use what you need,
and for this problem,
we needed H11.
We worked it out.
There it is.
This is a complete equation
that describes, for me,
the behavior of mass
1 per unit input force
as a function of frequency.
And it will always have a point
right there that it goes to 0.
And we don't have any damping
in here, so intuitively,
what do you think damping
will do to this plot?
What's the first thing
it does to the peaks?
What?
They become?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Finite.
And so the small damping, you're
going to have very high tops.
More damping, they're
going to be lower.
So damping especially
affects the peaks.
Damping will also pull this
off the bottom a little bit.
It won't perfectly go to 0.
So I want to do a
very particular case.
So an obvious one is
your original system.
It might be just a mass
spring with a rotor in it
that's unbalanced, and it's
running near resonance,
and it's vibrating like crazy.
A single degree of freedom
system vibrating like crazy.
Can I put on a second mass
spring and stop the motion?
Well, we can theoretically.
And we'll just say
let's let the problem
we're trying to solve--
that first system had
a natural frequency.
I'll call it cap omega n that
was the square root k1 over m1,
and I'm going to let that be
equal to square root of k2
over m2.
So I've now chosen
k2 and m2 such
they're exactly at
the natural frequency
of the original single
degree of freedom system.
So this is the
original system, k1 m1,
and it has that
natural frequency.
And now I'm going to stick
on a second mass, k2 m2,
but the value k2/m2 of
the second little system--
by itself, it has the same
natural frequency as the first
if you want to think
of it that way.
If I make this fixed,
what's the natural frequency
of that mass and spring?
Same natural frequency.
I'm just making it that way.
So this is now my system.
That's the parameters,
and now we can--
I'm going to give you
a plot of the response
of that particular system.
You know how we
non-dimensionalize
the single degree of
freedom transfer function?
We set x divided by
the static motion.
I want to do that again here.
So let's look at this system.
It's a two degree
of freedom system.
It has a force F1 on it, and
as the frequency goes to 0
and has displacement x1 and
x2-- so at omega equals 0,
x1 equals x1s.
I'll call it x1 static.
And how much is it?
So what's the
static displacement
at 0 frequency of this
system to that force?
Come on.
It's just a spring and a force.
How much will that
spring stretch
when you put a force F1 on it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: F1/k.
So x1 static equals F1/k1.
And F2 is 0.
There's no F2 force.
So how much is x2 static?
There's no forces
on the second mass.
How much will it move?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It just moves the
same amount as a first mass.
So this is x2 static, because
the forces on the system
are F1 and 0.
There's no force in this.
It's not going to do
anything to that spring.
It'll just move with
the whole system.
So I want to plot
x1 over x1 static.
In general, x1 is a function
of frequency-- is F1 times--
and I'm going to do
the magnitudes here--
times the magnitude of H11.
And I'm going to divide
that by F1 over k1.
So the F1's go away.
k1 comes in the numerator.
This looks like k1 h11.
So a plot of k1 magnitude h11.
We know roughly what
it's going to look like.
It has a peak.
It has a 0.
It has another peak.
Over here, this plot goes to 1.
There's x1 over-- this is
also x1 over x1 static.
Same thing.
It goes to 1.
Here it goes to 0.
Here is omega 1.
Here is omega 2.
And right here you're at
the original cap omega n,
because that's the way
we've designed this thing,
and we know this is
the way H11 behaves.
It goes to 0 at the
value we've chosen
for square root of k2/m2.
So we started out with
an original system that
had a natural frequency here.
k1/m1 was right here.
We stuck on this
second little mass,
and it made into a two
degree of freedom system.
It no longer has a
natural frequency there.
It has a natural
frequency below it,
and a natural
frequency above it,
and a 0 right where the
original natural frequency was.
Imagine what's going
on in the system.
You've got this force being
applied to the first mass,
and the first mass isn't moving.
Do you think the
second mass is moving?
Think about the free body
diagram of the first mass.
F equals ma.
There is a force on that first
mass-- F1 cosine omega t--
and it's not moving.
Mx1 double dot is 0.
So in order for the thing not
to move, there's a force on it.
There must be some other
force exactly canceling it.
Where does it come from?
AUDIENCE: Mass two.
PROFESSOR: Mass two
through the spring.
OK, so I'd also like
to know, what is x2?
Well, x2 from our
transfer function matrix
is the response of 2 due
to a force at 1 times F1,
plus a response at 2 due
to a force at 2 times F2,
but that second term
is 0 because F2 is 0.
That's a one term
expression, and H21
is z11 over the denominator.
And Z11-- so x2 is
going to look like that.
I wrote that wrong.
This is not z11.
It is z minus z12 like that.
And if you work that
out, it's F1 times k2
over the same denominator, but
let's evaluate-- here's our--
this is the frequency
we've been interested in.
Let's evaluate the response
of x2 right at this operating
point.
So let's evaluate this at
omega equals cap omega n.
So that's k2 down here
minus omega squared
m1 plus k1 plus k2.
It's the same
denominator as always.
k2-- I'm not going
to write it out.
It's exactly the
same thing as before,
but I want to plug in to this
denominator the operating
frequency.
We're going to operate
at cap omega n, which
is k1/m1 squared--
square root of k1/m1,
or square root of k2/me.
I'm going to plug in in this,
and let's see what we get.
And I'm going to let omega
equal k1/m1 or k2/m2.
It's the same thing, and
I'm plug them in whatever
is convenient.
So here I'm going to put
k1/m1, N1 and the m1's are
going to cancel.
I'll be left an k1.
F1 over k1 and down in
the denominator, this term
turns into k1/m1, so that's
minus k1 plus k1 plus k1.
Those two cancel.
I just get a k2.
Over here, I'll use minus
k2/m2 times m2 plus k2,
and that gives me
a minus k2 plus k2.
This whole thing goes to 0, and
I'm left with minus k2 squared
and in the denominator a k2.
This whole thing
turns into F1 over k2.
So the total response of that
second mass at this operating
frequency is just F1 over k2.
And I would like to plot it as
what does x2 over x1 static--
and x1 static and x2
static are the same.
Well, that is F1 over
k2 over F1 over k1.
The F1's go away,
and I get k1/k2.
That also happens to
be m1/m2, and it's
a quantity we call 1 over mu.
And we have just designed what's
called a dynamic absorber.
And a dynamic absorber
is a little device
you can use to stop vibration.
So when we were talking
about vibration isolation
and vibration mitigation
a few days ago
and I said you've got some
rotating imbalance [INAUDIBLE]
or something to
shake, well, give me
three ways of solving it.
We said balance the rotor.
What were the other two ways of
perhaps reducing the vibration?
AUDIENCE: Adding a
[INAUDIBLE] damper?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but also if you've
got something that's
shaking like crazy,
and it's putting
fibrillation into the floor
or into the table,
you can isolate it
with a mass and a spring, or
a microscope over here that's
vibrating like crazy,
you can isolate it
with a mass or a spring.
So this is to stop a
vibration isolation, which
is guaranteed to
be on the final--
the simple practical
applications of single degree
of freedom stuff.
So we have three
ways-- fix the rotor,
isolate it with a
mass and a spring,
isolate the sensitive
instrument mass and a spring.
Now you have a fourth way.
If it's a particular
operating frequency,
we can operate right
here with this thing
called the dynamic absorber.
This mu quantity is
called the mass ratio.
That's m2/m1.
Basically, these
things are real.
They're actually used
in real machines,
and usually you can't-- this
dynamic absorber thing you
stick on there can't be as
big as the original system.
It's going to be some small
fraction of the original system
size-- 5% or 10%
if you're lucky.
So the bigger this
thing is, you'll
find out the better it works.
So how much is this little
second mass bouncing around?
Well it's bouncing around
compared to x1 static
in the ratio of k1 to k2, which
is this 1 over mu quantity.
So if mu is 10%-- if you've
added the second mass,
it's 10% the size
of the first one.
1 over mu is a factor of 10.
So this transfer
function basically
looks-- do I have some
colored-- so the x2/x1 transfer
function basically behaves
the same right here
and pretty much the
same way out here.
And in here, it comes down
like this and comes back up.
And this height right
here is 1 over mu.
So the smaller you make this
thing, the tinier you make it,
the more it has to shake to
force the first mas to go to 0.
So basically, the reason this
thing works-- the free body
diagram-- at the 0 point, the
main mass m1, x1 equals 0 here.
It's not moving.
It's got a force acting on it
that is some F1 cosine omega t.
It's got a spring
force acting on it
from this second mass going.
Here is m2 over here, and
it's going back and forth
like crazy putting force
through this spring.
And the spring force had better
be exactly equal to that.
So the F spring is going
to be equal to minus F1,
and that will be
equal to x2 times kx2.
The second mass
has to move enough
that it'll compress the
spring enough that it provides
a force equal and
opposite to this one
so that it's in equilibrium
and it doesn't move.
All right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
building, if you
want the masses to be
fairly equal to each other,
how is that ever
going to happen?
PROFESSOR: It's not.
Not usually.
Dynamic absorbers are
used in real things,
like the Hancock Building.
And they're used in engines.
They're used in all
sorts of little devices
that you're not aware
they they're there.
And you have to
usually hide them
inside the footprint
of the original device.
So you don't want
them-- for a real thing,
you don't want to have a pump
with this huge appendage on it.
It's just not practical.
So they tend to be small.
And so, as a
consequence, in order
to make them work at this
particular frequency,
you have to vibrate like crazy.
So the design cost of
one of these things
is you have to design to be
able to allow this second mass
to shake like all get out.
Now, how many frequencies
does this work at?
Once you've designed it, it
only works at one frequency,
so this is only
useful for something
that has a fixed
operating frequency,
like a synchronous motor.
This isn't a good
thing for something
that has a range of frequencies
over which it can work,
but it is a different,
more complicated theory.
There's a type of
dynamic absorber
that you can make work over
a wide range of frequencies.
I need to tell you
one other thing.
When we put this thing on,
the original natural frequency
of the first system was here,
and it created two new ones.
You had a further question.
AUDIENCE: So how does making
it vibrate like that help?
It's only going to work
at that one frequency,
and you're always
going to have that gap.
So making it
vibrate really fast,
how does that help at all?
PROFESSOR: If, for
some reason, you really
don't want that
first thing to shake,
this makes it stop
shaking at that frequency.
So for example, one of the
widest distributed textbooks
in the world was written by an
MIT professor named Den Hartog,
and it's called
Mechanical Vibration.
It was written in the 1930s.
It's got a wonderful chapter
on dynamic absorbers in it.
And the example that he
gives of a real device that
actually uses one was
an electric hair clipper
that a barber uses.
The head on a hair
clipper-- it has
to go back and forth like
this in or to cut the hair.
That is an oscillating mass,
and you're going to feel it.
You're going to feel the mass
times the acceleration-- ma
omega squared acceleration--
at the frequency it runs that.
So they did a clever thing.
They built inside the
case of this thing
a little second mass and spring.
And so that when you're
holding the clippers,
it doesn't feel like it's-- OK?
So that was an example.
It was actually a great
example in his 1938 textbook.
And just so you
know, you really do
have two natural frequencies
when you do this,
and I'll write them like this.
Omega 1 squared
and omega 2 squared
are the original
frequency squared times 1
plus mu over 2 plus or
minus mu plus mu squared
over 4 square root.
So as your mass
ratio gets bigger,
the two frequencies move
further and further apart.
When the mass ratio
is 0, this quantity--
they have two
natural frequencies.
It goes to 1 natural frequency.
It's a single degree
of freedom system,
and it's at the original value.
As the mass ratio gets bigger
and bigger, these two roots--
this one and this one-- as you
add mass to that second system,
they spread apart.
And the bigger the mass ratio,
the further apart the two
natural frequencies become.
So we've got 10 minutes
left, and I have a demo
which illustrates this thing.
It's a little delicate
to make it work,
because actually it
was really frustrating.
I had it all set up.
It worked great in my office.
Came in 10 minutes early
today to set it up,
and the table in here is
so flexible I can't make
it behave like a fixed surface.
So I tweaked it, and I
think I've got running now,
but now what it is
is a beam with my pen
on it, my little squiggle pen.
And you've seen this before.
It's a rotating mass.
It's a static imbalance.
It shakes this beam.
And I've added to it
a second little beam.
It's a little blade of steal
with a heavy magnet on it.
That's my m2.
This is my k2-- is
this little beam.
This is the original
system, a mass,
it's close to a
natural frequency,
and the rotation rate
of the eccentric mass
is right at the natural
frequency of this beam.
So because it's
delicate to set up,
I've got to show you the system
first with the second mass
attached to it, and I
think I've got it tweaked
so that it'll sit there.
It's right at the
operating point,
and you ought to see the
second mass moving like crazy,
and the original mass, the
beam, not moving much at all.
So let's see if we
can make it work.
We're going to need
to kill the lights.
And you can see in here the
rotating mass going around
and around, and so I
have the strobe light
detuned just a little bit so
that you can see the system.
It's not quite synchronous.
Watch this little
white blob out here.
You see it going up and down.
That's your second mass,
and is the main beam--
it's moving a little
bit, but not much.
It's got a little
damping, and so it
isn't perfectly down at that
0 point, but very close.
So this is the system operating
close to that null point.
So now if I remove
the dynamic absorber,
the second little mass spring
system, then the main mass
and the beam ought
to shake like crazy.
Just changing the
tuning a little here.
So now I'm going to
remove the absorber.
All right?
And now it's going like crazy.
So that's an illustration.
You can come up with the lights.
Now, you hear beating?
This little pen-- this
little rotor in here
is driven by a little DC
motor and a single AA battery,
and it's not
feedback controlled.
Its frequency can vary,
and it isn't that powerful.
So as this thing starts
moving up and down,
it actually takes real torque
to make that weight go around
while this whole system is
accelerating up and down.
And the motor just
isn't up to it,
just isn't powerful enough,
so the speed changes.
This thing can't hold
constant frequency.
So that's the demo.
Questions?
So we've kind of embedded in
this lecture-- this lecture was
to introduce you to the idea
that you can write a transfer
function for a multiple
degree of freedom system--
has embedded in it all
the natural frequencies
of the system.
When you use a transfer
function to calculate
the response of the system, you
are getting the contributions
of all the modes at once.
So you essentially solve the
equations of motion directly.
So you now have seen
there's two ways
to go about analyzing multiple
degree of freedom systems--
the technique known as modal
analysis-- one mode at a time
and then add it together.
Or like with transfer
functions, where you're just
solving the whole thing at
once, and each transfer function
has in it all of the information
about all of the modes
of the system.
So if it's a five degree
of freedom system,
you're going to see
five peaks out here.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So this
is for [INAUDIBLE]?
But initially, since
you have a [INAUDIBLE],
does it have to start out moving
to be an [INAUDIBLE] moving
and then it stops.
PROFESSOR: So there's going
to be a transient phase, sure.
Any system, when
you start it up,
is going to have transients,
and the transients
are the equivalent of
initial conditions.
So displacement and
velocity-- and the response
of a linear system
that vibrates,
that has natural frequencies
to a set of initial conditions,
is vibration at
what frequencies?
AUDIENCE: Do you know
how they overcome
this in helicopters?
[INAUDIBLE] that we saw
at the beginning of the year?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the helicopter-- so
I want to answer the question.
Response to that transience
is at the natural frequencies
of the system, maybe
some combination.
The original
displacement requires
contributions of several modes.
You'll get decay
contributions at each
of the natural frequencies,
and once they've died out,
this motor has started up.
The thing will settle into what
we call steady state response,
and it will only be at
the excitation frequency.
And I haven't show
you anything about--
can you solve the equations of
motion from start up at time 0
through the whole
messy transient phase
to steady state?
Sure.
And we haven't talked
at all about that.
And actually, for vibration
stuff, it is very important.
Steady state answer
is important.
The transient answer
is pretty important,
and for you to have
a feeling for that,
you actually know quite a fair
amount about the basic concepts
of how things vibrate now.
Now, your question
about the helicopter--
so if you have a
uniform helicopter
blade-- they rigged
that to do what it did.
I don't know what they
were experimenting with,
but if you do-- there's a
problem that I've actually
given in a vibration course.
If you design a really
simple helicopter
that has a uniform blade.
It's a uniform rod, and
it's pivoted at the center,
and you spin it up,
and if you spin it
fast enough-- if
you spin it slowly,
it will droop because of
gravity, but if you spin it
fast enough, r omega squared
is a lot bigger than g.
And the thing flattens
out, and the blades
are going around and around.
The natural frequency
of that system
is exactly the rotation rate.
A uniform blade pivot at the
center, going around fast,
has a natural
frequency like this.
It happens to be exactly
at the rate of rotation.
So any perturbation will
start it doing bad things.
Helicopters are never
ever designed like that.
The helicopter has a
rotor disk in here,
has a finite radius
before the pin,
and then the blades
are out here.
The pin around which-- and
that changes the resonance
frequency.
And of course, you can
change the mass distribution
in the blade and so forth.
So what they had
done in that case
to rig it so the thing beat
itself to death, I don't know.
But there's good design
practices with helicopters
so that the blade frequency
is not at the rotation rate,
because at rotation
rate, you're going
to have a lot of excitation,
hitting turbulence in the air
and so forth.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that you use something
like this in the
Hancock Building,
but I would imagine that the
wind force on the Hancock
Building does not have a
uniform frequency all the time.
So is the idea that
[INAUDIBLE] control
based on resonant
frequency [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I've forgotten
the correct name now,
even though I've used
these many times now.
The optimally tuned and
damped dynamic absorber
is sort of the second level
of dynamic absorber design.
Typically, a two degree
of freedom system
looks like that if
it's lightly damped,
but you can design that second
mass spring and a damper
so that you can make
the transfer function,
H11 here, look like
this, where you
get the two peaks are of
equal height, and the worst--
and you can design them so
that the worst case amplitude
response over here
is pretty low.
x1 static is square
root of 1 over 1
plus mu or something like that.
So the bigger you make this,
the better the performance,
but you have to have
optimum damping,
and you have to
have optimum tuning.
And tuning means, if
the there were-- we
tune this thing
so that k2/m2 was
exactly equal to a particular
frequency, in this case k1/n1.
But for the optimally tuned
and damp dynamic absorber,
you actually tune things-- it's
tuned a little differently.
You put damping in
it, and you make
it behave pretty well
over the entire frequency,
range rather than almost
perfect at one frequency.
And the Hancock Building had its
transfer function, so to speak,
without the dynamic absorber--
it has many, many peaks,
but it had two problematic ones
that were very close together,
and they were at about 0.8
radians per second, and 0.81,
or something.
And this was bending,
and this was torsion.
And at these two resonances--
and the wind would come along,
and it would excite
both of them.
And the one resonance was
just the same as this thing.
It just bends.
And the other resonance was
the first mode in torsion.
So if you were standing on one--
and a building cross section
is a funny-- the
Hancock Building
looks kind of like
that in cross section,
and so it would rotate in
torsion and deflect in bending.
So it would be rotating
and deflecting,
and if they were
in equal amounts
and they're close in frequency,
if you're standing up there,
what would you feel?
They would beat.
The motion would beat.
You'd get a lot of
motion, because if you
are on one end of
the building, you'd
get a lot of torsional
motion out here combined
with the bending motion.
And then they would
cancel, and then the beat
would build up again.
And so that was what was
happening in the building.
And they put in two, so on
the 58th floor on each end
they put in a mass spring system
and over here another one so
that they would resist
the torsion-- actually,
really I lined them
up the wrong way.
They line up this way.
So it has two of them.
They can resist both the
bending and the torsion.
They each weigh
300 tons, and they
it's a box filled up with
50 pound lead bricks.
And the box is about-- it's been
20 years since I was up there,
but what I recall is this
like 8 by 10 feet yea tall.
And it slides on a pressurized
oil film, and the spring on it
is a big pneumatic
spring, a big air spring,
and a computer runs
the whole system.
It's shut down until the wind
gets above 40 miles an hour,
and then turns it on.
And it's actually
kind of self tuning.
It can optimize itself,
and then it'll sit there,
and it's designed to do this,
because this building has
these two problem frequencies.
And so it has been designed
to address both of them.
All right, I think I have to get
out of here for the next class.
See you next Tuesday.
Last lecture.